Last week,
I did a You 'Laugh You Lose'.
Skrattar du, förlora du!
and I challenged
Green PewDiePie
and Thanos PewDiePie
But no one accepted my challenge
A bunch of cowards!
So here I am,
and here you are.
Smash LIKE to accept the challenge
Skrattar du, förlora du.
Let's freakin do this guys!
Hey! Another Thanos meme!
*squeak*
By the way, if I laugh
I get 3 lives
Add the lives!
That's right, I'm fine, I'M FINE OKAY!
*squeak*
Where is that from?
wait wait wait wait
Oh yeah! It's this guy!
*deep inhale*
*squeak*
**claps**
THE LEGEND!
My highest note
*squeak*
Oh my god!
Let me try
AAH!
I love how he's so serious about it
Is he serious? He has to be trolling right?
This is a troll
*squeak*
I feel like it's not a troll *laugh*
A classic meme
A classic meme.
Alright let's keep going
And remember the rules guys! No laughing, okay?
Otherwise
Okay!
Alright
You need more men
There are none
*laugh*
That was an amazing edit
Could this possibly be a new meme edit that hasn't been defiled by the duck and grand-gay
*laugh*
A new template that doesn't involve stupid marvel movies
That would be great thank you very much
Skrattar Du!
So far I have one more life guys
HOOF!
cOMe oN!
*inaudible*
This is not some kind of GAME!
*dazed and confused*
I think I need to rewatch that one
Nope
No I will not
I am not grinning, oKaY
BE QUIET!
This is not me laughing or grinning I am choosing to smile
Because I've *laugh*
I'm making myself laugh! REVIVE ONE POINT!
*clap* that's right got 2 lives
What do you want? It's my game, my rules!
Be quiet
You can't even talk
Skrattar du, förlora du has been sponsored by
Any drinking company, wanna sponsor me.. Please this could be you
Oh no
No
No.
HE'S WEARING HEADPHONES
NO
Oh wow! THANOS CAR is in avengers 4!
Thanos car is in-
Okay this is really cool
I think you know, the video i did criticizing marvel movies
I'm gonna go ahead and say I was wrong
Did he just say car?
*laugh*
THAT DOES NOT COUNT!
Gee I wOndEr whAT the mEme is gOinG to be?
Oh wow! It's thanos car!
*laugh*
Thanos car! *clap*
Thanos car is still kicking it!
That's right
You see a thanos car, you get in.. there's no choice
Why is thanos car still going?
AY!
AY LOOK!
ANOTHER MARVEL
Everything is marvel
Marvel has taken over
Damn
I was wrong, marvel is not for teenagers
They're for hardcore badasses
OH another spiderman-
Gwen dies
Hey look it's me! Good meme!
*laugh*
prodigy.exe applause for amazing edit
But the thing is I did the reaction thing so people would make gifs out of it
So we can ironically share gifs with each other
But instead of everyone treating it like a green screen competition
And, you did it wrong okay
You did it wrong
Excuse me!
What is this? South park?
People that annoy you *laugh*
Second time alright, I ONLY SAID IT ONCE!
I'm gonna put on my glasses of see through bs and say that he planted that
No one uses the word neg
Unless they wanna be racist
How is he still allowed to stream on this platform?
Yes
*laugh*
It really did look like tekashi to be fair
Is this the new damn daniel?
Kinda wanna get that hair now just for the memes
I love how you can see him laughing
This reminds me, let me show you one of my favorite clips of all time
This doesn't count cuz I've seen it and it's so good
Cuz it summarizes these games so beautifully
Chillax!
Stupid gun!
AAAAH I HATE YOU GUN! YOU SUCK!
*laugh*
The writing, so good
stupid.. stupid gun!
Wait! There's a clip of me!
Hey! Look at that! I can make funny clips too!